Harry Croteau discovered fullerenes the
molecules that kick-started the field of
carbon nano technology daddy Hirschbeck
has spent his career investigating the
molecular details of chemical reactions
both laureates are strong proponents of
science education and of encouraging the
public understanding of science they met
with three young physicists in a local
school on the island of lindau in
Germany to discuss these matters we're
Nobel Prize winners the day before the
Nobel Prize people knew we know nothing
new nothing but the day after we
suddenly well knew everything was more
remarkable than any chemical reaction
quick presently we had this immense
intelligence which everybody realized we
didn't have before hand I remember
walking across campus a student cameras
I'm so glad I had your course I'm pretty
sure that's what we hear you know we
have some friends in that in harvard and
some from UK also we hear that you guys
are great to do capers and it's all of
them talk then decide to either oh well
uh yeah i mean i think sums take a feel
a responsibility to speak on behalf of
the scientific community and I think
there are things that I want you to
think about and as far as I'm concerned
science is different from everything
else everybody else tells you what to
think scientists tell you how to think
and I think that's one of the big
problems today that large numbers of
people are not thinking about the issues
that we have they're just accepting what
people tell them for instance you
probably accept that the earth goes
round the Sun when it's quite obvious
that the Sun goes around the earth
all right yes isn't it I mean it is
absolutely the quite obvious this is
interesting that is so obvious that the
Sun goes around the earth do you think
the sun goes round here I don't why um
because I think some pretty smart people
work that out before me and I I trust in
physics you trust them I didn't trust
anything I mean no I this is a big
problem that you're probably too
trusting you have accepted that but in
Galileo's time but they didn't trust
Galileo right no but I think I think
there's a difference in and what you're
asked who you should trust and who you
shouldn't trust if you're if you're
speaking to a fourth-grade classroom I
think it's a lot to ask of them to
immediately distrust everything you're
saying I mean if we want to get
somewhere if we want kids to feel
comfortable with science we need we need
to give them a foundation of the things
that that we know you've got a very good
point but there is a museum it just out
Cincinnati which is teaching young
children in bus Rose schoolkids are
going at that age to this museum and
they're being told that the Grand Canyon
was carved by Noah's Flood where they're
being told that the fossils of animals
and dinosaurs were drowned in Noah's
Flood did humans live with Dinosaurs God
made Adam and Eve on the same day as
land animal so dinosaurs and people
lived at the same time what did they
originally eat before Adam send all
animals including dinosaurs with
vegetarian you don't need those teeth to
eat lettuce and why is that museum so
successful for something like that
because they don't ask people to
question those things they tell them
there's a very fine line when we as
scientists are talking to people who are
non-scientists teaching them when it's I
don't use the word correct but when you
should be skeptical what we mean when we
say series what we say theory as if is a
theory to other physicists is entirely
different than what the general public
interprets the word the various so when
people present things as facts they take
them to be true when physicists speak to
the public and they say well we have
this theory we mean we know something
almost certainly and so I think that
just opens it up to the skepticism a lot
of people certainly older generation
they want to be told what to think they
don't want to have to think for
themselves and like particularly on
policies such as climate change they
want to have a definitive body that
comes to them and says here's the
evidence go you know make your decision
you need to give people a certain answer
when they ask you a question because we
we don't want to leave them with the
impression that well we've done nothing
but we should also not not turn our
unscientific velocity which is that we
should question everything what you need
to get kids into science is to let them
play or to let them explore science
think for themselves and I think there
would be very few people that would say
anything against that yet absolutely
nothing is being done to change that
radically in school sure you can change
the syllabus to make them you know do a
bit more things that are relevant to
modern-day physics but they're still not
giving them the opportunity to do the
experiments themselves if a student in
elementary school middle school or high
school where to watch this video I
guarantee we would turn half of them
away immediately because they see
science as this thing done with beakers
and Bunsen burners and all of these
other things and that conjures up a
certain image for them almost right off
of the bat because they think of people
as the ones who want to be in science
classrooms I mean being in science
classrooms right now for a lot of kids
is not an enjoyable experience so it's
not being in a room such as this or
bringing up images of beakers or
molecules or things like that isn't
going to make a kid want to engage more
when they already have these negative
views is is such a huge public
perception thing yeah already and like
how do you go about changing public
perception like this is a stereotype
that's portrayed in every form of media
that scientists are geeks and how do you
even go about addressing that I've
always thought from my experience that
students interact like high school
students interact so well with graduate
students they they see them as
accessible people to talk to you've got
to find a way to funnel graduate
students educated people that commune
communicate effectively into schools and
ideally lower level schools
yet people excited we're doing that a
bit with the internet because we are
outreach initiative is is using graduate
students and undergraduates to tell high
school students what their projects are
on what the direct University turns out
that some of the best teachers are you
guys because you're the same age as
these people and what's more you're
still passionate about something I
suppose to me I said you know okay well
I so passionate you seem awfully
passionate but talking about education
and outreach and things like that and I
know at least in the United States it's
almost a deterrent if not is a deterrent
I i I've talked to many yeah if you have
if you have outreach on your CV then
it's seen as you were spending time
doing this outreach education thing you
weren't spending time in the lab doing
your research the people who are going
to hire me are going to care about what
quality of work I do what members i have
written and unfortunately the american
system is set up such that it rewards
that and not outreach
all the laureates here are old men so
there are wide oh maybe I think I think
a lot of the things you can say about
women in physics you can say about
ethnic minorities yes I want to talk to
under-representation there's something
that's kind of weeding them out of the
process if you have more women and
minorities at the top then the
recruitment becomes a lot easier yes do
you feel that it's a problem that's
something like here at at lindau every
Nobel attendee is male or we have to
make way past it but when they did their
science and when they've started to
become science as they were young people
Einstein was 17 when he first started to
think about what it was like to travel
the velocity of light the image the icon
of the scientists Ison is responsible
for that as the old guy 60 70 years old
so it couldn't be a woman with crazy
gray hair or a lab coat on I mean that's
one way that were it physics is seems to
be a bit different because I think it's
very tough for women it's certainly
probably partly if they want to have
children it means that they in general
there's a break and they even a short
break of six months I think it's like
rolling at getting a snowball building
it up when you've built it up after it
becomes easier to get it to roll down
the hill if you stop that thing now
you've got to now get this big snowball
to start rolling again but if you make
it to the point where you're starting a
family if you are still in the field if
you have still gotten to that point in
your career path you've had to jump
several other hurdles on the way there
that is certain that's one of the the
end that's one of the like you're barely
making it you just like struggle and
fall over the finish line kind of
hurdles to get over there are so many
others from from middle school to high
school to undergrad to graduate school I
mean I'm not thinking about a family you
know yeah
much much of the much of the women in my
graduate program are not bigoted yeah
yeah I mean there are many reasons why
they drop out and I'd like to chip in
ill it is as the issue I've been very
long concerned with first of all I've
two daughters my wife is a PhD in
organic chemistry and I've been a very
aware of this all the way back one
reason I think everyone agrees you two
are back there view so few women in
physics compared with more civilized
feels like chemistry and biology and all
is this business that girls tend to be
told early on you can't do mathematics
as of course an absurd myth nothing we
know that just make that true but we
have two daughters first daughter she
acquiesced in that second daughter had
such a personality that she wasn't going
to go along when they were telling her
such a thing so she became very good at
mathematics you you need women at the
top to promote to the women underneath
and that eventually will feed down to
the high school level but at the moment
there's just a lack of women at the top
the demography of Nobel laureates is
very typical of the world as a whole I
will not be surprised that is not so far
distant future people will be asking
where the white men they are in the
lineup of Nobel laureate all in the
general issue what I felt was that there
was a
I disconnect between our generations
right yeah so it's as if they did not
understand the issue perhaps with the
level of detail that we did I almost
felt like at the end of that
conversation that we have to be the ones
coming up with the solutions for for the
issues that our generation thinks
there's such a cultural gap that we have
to be the one that find the solution ray
I've met parents who told me that their
children hide the fact that they are
interested in science from their
colleagues okay and I think that's a
problem because it's not perceived as
being something which they're proud of
being good at the sizes those
intellectual pursuits are not perceived
within the peer group as being this and
that's got to be changed they all want
to be David Beckham they won't want to
be supermodels I don't disagree with
that but I think the difference between
an athlete or a model or something like
this is those are professions where
people are told if you work hard you can
do it from the very beginning I feel
like kids are sort of told you either
have the skill for math or science or
you don't I don't think that there's the
same the same idea that if you sit down
and you really study or you really work
at it or you really want to be a
scientist that you can get from the
bottom of the list to the top of the
list and not mention that's a complete
stereotypes was like I'm bad at math and
it's fine to just throw the Hat yes
exactly and I think we need to change
that I think that first needs to change
because right away if you do bad in a
course you're gonna be like I'm writing
this off math is not for me because it's
not ingrained in me so i think when i go
back one of the things i'm going to take
is just being a role model doing things
even if they're not really overtly
sciency i just want to go out and
present myself as a scientist or as a
physicist
kind of be a person that someone can say
hey they went through this and they have
similarities to me maybe I can do it and
I think doing that in a subtle way not
being like I'm going to do an experiment
for you make it fun we find it fun and
we need to find a way to make it fun for
them as well i know i think we can yeah
you
you